[Music]
so there's this scientific agency in
Britain called the Natural Environment
Research Council their big government
body and they've got a new ship coming
they've got a 300 million dollar new
arctic explorer vessel and they're very
excited about it and they recognized
that we're living in this world of
crowds where everyone wants to
participate and we're all finding a way
to express ourselves and they have this
idea and they say let's launch a
campaign called hash tag name our ship
now this campaign is off to a slightly
whirring start because they launched it
with a press release and the press
release says hash tag name of our ship
maybe you the public would like to name
it something like Shackleton or endeavor
or adventurer now these aren't the kinds
of names the public come up with within
a day someone has tweeted in we should
call this ship boaty mcboatface and
boaty mcboatface is immediately and
virally popular I should say the in 10th
place
boaty mcboatface was first in 10th place
and I thought this was somewhat
neglected was I like big boats and I
cannot lie but in any case both my boat
face does terrifically well it goes
viral everyone is talking about it it's
on all the front pages of the newspapers
there are literally hundreds of millions
of Twitter impressions about this there
in the pubs there are dinner tables the
whole nation and in fact the whole world
it crosses the ocean it's covered by the
New York Times and CNN the whole world
gets excited and obsessed with boaty
mcboatface but there's a problem
the the science Minister takes a very
dim view of this this is a very big
investment of government money this is
not a serious name for a boat this nuts
this must be you in a put down
immediately when things must be put back
in their place and this government
agency is in a really tough spot so on
one hand they've got the public who is
incredibly excited about the idea of
boaty mcboatface on the other hand the
science Minister is saying this is not
taking a science seriously and they end
up really in a moment which tells us
something about our age which is what
they were trying to do they were trying
to work out ok there's a there's a crowd
out there we want to harness their
energy who they want to do that in a
powerful way they were trying to do that
but they had none of the skills you
might need to think about harnessing the
crowds in the end what they do is they
call it Sir David Attenborough who's
this very famous British scientist which
no one could really complain about too
much and they named one of the small
submarines on top of this boat boaty
mcboatface so they literally sunk Botti
at sea so here's the question what could
they have done differently you think
about this moment you think about this
huge surge of enthusiasm around science
and just imagine if instead of putting
boaty out to the side instead they lent
into it and they'd said let's embrace
this let's think about how we can engage
a generation of kids in maritime science
let's think about how we could
merchandize this let us think about all
the different moments that Bochy could
dock around the nation and you could
imagine whole groups of people coming
out to learn more about Arctic
exploration and they did none of those
things and and what that teaches us is
firstly never ever ask the crowd to name
anything it will always always go wrong
but it tells us something else too is
there's a set of very clear skills in
how you go about harnessing the crowd
and you look around the world right now
and any corporation any nonprofit any
leader who wants to come out on top
needs to think a lot more carefully
about how they negotiate with the crowd
and we see four things that really help
organizations and leaders get this kind
of thing right the first is strategy do
you really need the crowd you know that
this research council didn't really need
any help naming the boat they already
knew what they wanted to call it so it
wasn't strategic in a very real way
number two do you have legitimacy with
the crowd there was a famous moment
where JP Morgan tried a version of this
and they did a hashtag campaign called
ask JP em now this was shortly after the
financial challenges and crisis and of
course instead of people tweeting in
questions like how do I become a bank
our people tweeted in things like how
dare you and how do you sleep at night
so it's a question around legitimacy do
you have legitimacy with the
crowd if you're entering this this world
number three is control are you prepared
to give up some control to others you
know what was really interesting about
boating with boat phases they weren't
prepared to give up control as soon as
the crowd took this somewhere they
didn't want to go they shut the
experiment down if you're engaging with
the crowd you have to honor that crown
you have to be able to say if you come
up with something we don't expect we
will embrace the outcome that you've
encouraged and then finally commitment
the fourth thing which is really
important if you want to get this kind
of thing right is are you committed to
this in the long term what we see time
and again now is is leaders who once a
year will engage with the crowd and
they'll do some kind of Facebook live
event and they'll say let's be open to
new ideas and then I'll disappear to
their corner office for the rest of the
year and one of the key things in
engaging with the crowd and you can
learn this from anyone particularly
activists who've mobilised is this is a
muscle you have to strengthen day after
day after day so as we think about how
we engage with the world we need to
avoid boaty mcboatface moments and by
doing that find ways of really getting
the crowd and getting the value out of
the crowd that we can benefit from an
organization who really got these
dynamics right was Lego so Lego was the
I guess about 15 years ago everything
was not very awesome with Lego they were
almost bankrupt they had spent all this
money on theme parks and wristwatches
things were going very badly for the
company and they were close to
collapsing and they and they recognized
this was just when the internet was was
beginning they recognized there was a
group of people out there who had
enormous value to offer who they hadn't
previously engaged with and they will
call that Apple's the adult fans of Lego
and these were these people largely men
who had been building Lego up into their
past their childhood into their adult
lives often in secret and they all began
to realize there were others of them
like that around the world and so as the
internet rose so did this group of
assholes around the world and what Lego
realized was was that these people
brought huge value to their brand so not
only were they out spending kids 20 to 1
but they were doing things like creating
new sets Lego had never dreamed of or
creating whole fan events that Lego had
never dream
and what Lego then did over a decade
which was so smart is they structured
for participation they built their whole
brand around finding ways to invite
their crowd to engage with them in
meaningful ways and I'll give you a
couple of examples one thing they did
even the recent lego movie many of the
lines and ideas in the movie was sourced
from their fan base and they did
something else too as they opened up
their innovation to their fan base so
you now can submit your own ideas for
what the next lego set should be there
was one female scientist who was that an
apple when she had never shown anyone
her LEGO creations apart from her
husband but she thought that women
scientists were very badly
underrepresented in Lego so she put
together this very cool kit of female
scientists and put that forward over
10,000 people voted for it it was hugely
successful it did a great job of doing
some great PR for Lego and that set is
now in places all around the world and
so what Lego teaches is perhaps the key
skill of our age which is we need to
start recognizing the offering agency to
our broader community is what's making
the difference between success and
failure so I think the answer is to
think a lot less about hashtags and a
lot more around invitations because
ultimately participation there are lots
of hashtags which don't work at all
obviously because what they don't do is
offer people a real genuine chance to
participate so as you think about the
work of building for new power one of
the things to think about is what what
am I doing here which will be beneficial
to the people I want to engage with not
what they what can they do for me but
what can I do for them one of the people
we talk to inside Lego who's a company
who's done this very very well over the
years is she always asks herself the
first question she asked herself and
encourages her colleagues to ask
themselves is what am i bringing to the
party what is it I'm creating that will
make my crowd more valuable not what is
it I can do what is it they can do for
us I think that power dynamic is
actually very important in this work so
if you're looking to spread your ideas
or start a movement the first place to
begin that isn't here's my idea how can
more people get behind it
but how can I get behind more people
that's the right frame
[Music]
you